Esta es una redada en busca de actividad
ilegal de deforestación en Brasil una de
las primeras desde que el izquierdista
Lula da Silva asumir al poder el 1 de
enero se lleva a cabo en tierras remotas
de la amazonía brasileña que son una
reserva indígena protegida pese a ello
llevan años sufriendo deforestación
se gastan entre 580 y 966 dólares por
hectárea Así que una persona no va a
invertir si no sabe para que la va a
usar en el futuro Quién hizo esa
inversión creía que el gobierno
continuaría estaba una perspectiva
este agente del instituto de medio
ambiente y recursos naturales se refiere
al gobierno de Jair bolsonaro bajo el
cual hubo un aumento del 60% en la
deforestación Respecto a los 4 años
anteriores
el discurso del anterior gobierno creó
una mentalidad entre la gente haciendo
que muchos invadieran zonas y
deforestaron el gobierno de bolsonaro
había minimizado este tipo de redadas
fue un gobierno en el que se trabajó
solo para resolver problemas de
emergencia haciendo acciones puntuales
para decir que se estaba haciendo algo
Durante los anteriores gobiernos de Lula
entre los años 2003 y 2010 la
deforestación se redujo en un 72% con su
nueva Victoria la protección de la
amazonía se volvió una prioridad una
esperanza para los defensores del pulmón
del mundo que ven también un Aliado en
el gobierno de la vecina y también
amazónica Colombia